and it made you seem cozy people heard
that noise yeah what is it ah [ __ ]
people dropping drinks and [ __ ] as you
slow motion so so yeah it was a big deal
but you are an analog guy yeah do you
feel like that is your problem I know
that's like a big but you feel like
you're you are uncomfortable in a lot
it's like you seem at iLET you seem at
ease and then at the same time you feel
like you don't understand what's going
on some I just saw this recently man I
sometimes I have a I'm upset that time
moves so fast it's like I just I just
feel like I can't ever win I just can't
ever really get a grasp of what's going
on and it keeps happening you know and
it really does I think sometimes
frustrate me a little bit what is the
what what do you want to get a grasp on
I think just to feel like I'm kind of
inking that everything that I'm gonna be
able to control like I guess that I'm in
control you know that I'm okay you know
okay I got the hang of what's going on
now yeah without things neat changing so
much and is that within relationships or
that's within everything I think that's
just within existence really yeah so I
think yeah I just just thinking about
that the other day I just sometimes feel
you know not like it's a bad thing but
like I just realized oh wow I have this
this irrational idea that like almost a
resentment against time because I can't
get a Kentucky it won't let me grasp
everything at once you know it won't let
me
you can't organize everything is well as
you need to because it just keeps
happening it keeps going and and also
then I think because I'm probably lazy
sometimes and so it's like damn give me
a chance
broke your lazy time I don't I don't
know your schedule but you seem pretty
active yeah am I wrong uh I think I I
think I procrastinate I think sometimes
you know what I thought the other day
man I put I set this weird bar in my
mind that everything needs to be perfect
or like everything needs to be perfect
but then I also know this thing about
myself that I procrastinate sometimes
and so I will set both it's like I will
set the bar high oh yeah you know that's
one of the reasons people procrastinate
is fear of perfection mmm or not fear of
perfection they're perfectionists so
you're like well I can't start now
because I'll get to it's not right yet
like I don't have it set up you're gonna
fail you're gonna fail a lot of
procrastination is just fear of failure
yeah this is feeling like you can't and
then you'll start when you go well if I
don't I'm [ __ ] if I don't start now so
that's the only like the fear of being
[ __ ] is greater than the fear of being
imperfect mm-hmm and then if once you
get to that point you go okay they'll
start or like you have to start yeah I'm
that last-minute starter a lot of jobs
but things are working out for you man
yeah things are going okay man it's
crazy this year I got in so much fear
man I just got you know it's just and
I'm not trying to sound like ungrateful
or just yet this year was just [ __ ]
crazy brother it was just a crazy year
it was busy and it was hard and it was
what did you find hard about it because
I think people from the outside in
people would assume it was it's been
great for you it's if people would think
it's probably the best year your life
right yeah and I think I just couldn't
feel that I just couldn't I just think
just got real scared man I got real
scared right but what what up just like
of that things we're gonna I think for
one of not maybe knowing who I was as
things got more successful you know like
I'd always been this like I'd always
felt like I didn't have a chance a
little bit mhm and I'd always really
like that had always been something that
I really like carried me oh yeah you
were like an underdog yeah like an
underdog like the underdog who wouldn't
get you were getting [ __ ] and you were
they are not helping me and yeah
[ __ ] and yeah and then you and
you're like oh wait they you're not I
mean you are still but that's part of
your appeal yeah and I just didn't yeah
yeah I just but then I felt like I
didn't know how to be I don't know I
felt like I didn't know how to be
successful and then I got scared I
started to get real scared and I got
real like controlling
in this year like everything just I
wanted everything to be I needed help
and I was afraid to ask for help and so
then everything were felt like it was on
me what did you need help with just with
just with like touring and doing that
kind of stuff and being willing to like
just trust that other people know what's
good and I don't know I think I just had
like a lot of dislike I mean for me a
lot of it goes back to like my
alcoholism stuff it's just a lot of that
stuff just flared up like just fear just
came up everywhere
yeah it just came up everywhere man I
was just I don't know man I just got
kind of scared and it's not like a
self-pity thing I'm not feeling sorry
for myself like and I also I couldn't
feel gratitude I really needed to feel
grateful when I was and I felt so
grateful for for the past couple years
man and then I just I just had a tough
time man
and I just got real scared honestly bro
I got what were using what were you you
were afraid that it was all gonna go
away yeah I was afraid that I was just
gonna mess it up yeah you know I was
afraid that you know that I was a phony
I was afraid that I was like a liar just
I was afraid that I was no good just a
lot of just self-worth just didn't it
just was hard you know not in a bad way
I think the only thing that you would
[ __ ] up is if you weren't yourself yeah
I think that's the only that's the own
people like you because you are your
unique like just watching them known you
probably eight years or somebody's
watching you
it's been cool watching you go from I
gotta say your hair cut from the outside
in was a turning point seemingly yeah
cuz you you were just like trying to be
kind of like la you're appealing or
something or something I don't know what
you were trying to be just like a like
just more like everybody else
yeah and then you got then you started
doing this with your hair and it felt
like everything fell into place yeah
like oh like myself yeah like if you
felt like more like yourself and you you
like you started being more yourself
onstage yeah and being weirder on stage
and being more
regional or southern then you'd been
before yeah and and and then and then
you start a podcast it just felt like
all these things started happening in
sequence and from the outside end and
just a guy who sees you at night it
seemed like once you had that hair it
was like he's empowering wrong no it
felt a very empowering man I think all
my life - I've had a big nose I've
always been scared to have like like
real short hair cuz there's less things
to hide behind you know you're here's
the thing about you that I've always
said about you that you you're
good-looking and you don't think you are
yeah you are good-looking like I bet if
you they asked most 5s most women would
say you're like an eight yeah I say yeah
I thought brush my teeth I am an eight
but I believe everybody's an eight if
they take care if they clean up and they
take care of themselves I believe that
okay I don't agree okay
hi respectfully disagree with that but
you're and you're definitely an eight
because you're like kind of Tang and
olive skin you got night you know like
your was symmetrical the big nose thing
I don't think it's true I mean it's fine
I have a big nose but like it mine's
bigger than yours mom I love that lean
yeah I got that mind you know I got the
open nose maybe I love that [ __ ] Lee
yeah you had that tear that's got you
got like meat so yeah thing is [ __ ]
like a thought bro I feel like it should
be in a thong sometimes you got that
donk on your face man yeah so anyway
growing my hair longer once I was like
yeah and I think four years I'd try to
audition in Hollywood and been like I
just I hated it I [ __ ] hated going
auditions yeah absolutely hated it I
felt uncomfortable I just was scared
yeah I just didn't know I didn't like it
and I didn't want to admit that I didn't
like it I was afraid to say you know
what I don't like this I felt like I had
to do it and then yeah once I just kind
of I think oh I've never I saw some
pictures myself I said I'm never gonna
have real long hair you know I had it
when I was really young right but I'm
never gonna have it again unless I grow
it now and then once I grew my hair out
man I started to feel like a [ __ ] you
know like just like a king bruh just
like somebody who had a [ __ ] it's
like I'm gonna dick
back here head bro yeah it feels
empowering dude it's what it looks like
that cuz it's like hey you know what I'm
gonna look how I look
it then you I deal with it this looks
the way you probably fit looks like your
character yeah it looks like what I
would assume your character and it also
looks like your it looks like your
character like your your values and all
that [ __ ] but it also looks like the not
like Theo Vaughn's character but like
the thing that's funny about you is also
that yeah it's the guy that wants to an
adult that wants his hair like this in
2019 it's beautiful yeah is who you are
and that's like it [ __ ] yeah I don't
I'm glad that I was right about it cuz
it was like it seems like once he grew
his hair like this everything Jane yeah
yeah I guess I got scared to like say
that I wasn't feel it was hard for me to
tell how I was feeling and and then I I
was like nobody wants to hear somebody
who's doing well complain nobody wants
to hear him complain yeah and so that
kind of got tough for me too
like even on just the regular episodes
of this podcast just by myself to talk
about things because I just felt like
man I just I don't want to be I don't
wanna have self-pity but I don't know
what's going on right now I'm just you
know I'm just I was just I was just
scared
you know just scared really when I think
about it and how did it resolve or did
it it's just kind of resolving I'm just
like trying to get more like in a
12-step right now and just really
focusing on that and like were you not
doing that I was but it might hit my
that my program had gotten real small
whenever I was just working all the time
yeah you know my life got big and my
program got small yeah and I think I was
angry of being at some success because I
thought I would feel better yeah yeah
that's the other thing when I do you
think like well the if putting
conditions on your happiness yeah going
well I'm not happy now I'm not even
gonna allow myself to be happy not
because I don't deserve it
yeah and then you good [ __ ] happens and
and you're like
[ __ ] this didn't work either but yeah
what's gonna work the [ __ ] is gonna work
and what I I will say that it is
gratifying to be the times I've had like
you know weeks or months of like
attention is gratifying it feels good
yeah I mean it feels gratifying it feels
shallow to admit it but it feels good
when people yeah that feels good our ego
feels good we do good yeah nice whenever
people acknowledge you yes and but at
the same time it it shitty that you that
you that we life eel-like it's partially
like American to only be happy if you
accomplish X yeah and and I've been
trying to do a thing and it's very
degree success but where I might know
just give yourself that esteem for not
for not for nothing just for Y put it on
some why leave it up to a situation or
the way to make you feel good about you
should make it feel good it's like I can
just feel good because life is short
right and and like I you know it's like
I used to beat myself up for not being
as funny as blank and it's like alright
maybe I'm never gonna be as funny as
[ __ ] bill burr or or did Chris or
Dave or what it's like what so I'm
supposed to [ __ ] sulk my whole life
you know I wanna [ __ ] have a fun time
with my skill level and you're funny is
totally different to of course yeah of
course we're like I have different
talents right we don't recognize those
things we just yeah we set these things
and it's like yeah and it's yeah we just
set these comparisons and it's good for
business it is good for American
business when everyone feels insecure
that everybody feels like they got to
work harder and rise & grind and all
that right definitely but if you just
get to the point of like no I I'm I want
to have a fund I want to feel good yeah
like I meditate and then in the last two
minutes I just go like
just feel good in your body for no
reason yeah just just feel good your job
on in on earth is to feel good that's my
job to make myself to have as much
serotonin flowing through my body as I
posit own and jockiboi I don't
yeah like and and without without drugs
or drink whatever just getting things
going feeling that is they that to me is
the mark of a life well-lived yeah
how good did I feel minutes a minute is
the nice thing about 12-step programs
yeah is you're gonna try your that's
probably what you like about it oh yeah
man I just saw a guy at a gym this
morning last night I'm somewhere and I
see yeah I went to a meeting last night
now and it is man it's one of the things
that I didn't have here in LA yeah it's
like sitting just sitting across from
somebody and talking about we could talk
about how we feel like we can have
conversations like this a lot of times
where it's a little bit more like you
know cuz yeah just like about soil or
emotion I need help like hey I need help
I talk I have to call someone today and
tell them not good news and that kind of
heard something I have to make a call
and that stuff always scares me so it's
like now I can ask somebody who's done
it before or he's older than me who has
a business or something how do I do this
you know and they'll tell me that like
it's gonna be okay you know don't let it
spin in your head where you're up yeah
after the night you've had nine
conversations with the guy yeah now I
don't have to do that that [ __ ] doesn't
have to happen I can say okay you know
I'm powerless over the situation but
somebody else I know can help me yeah
and it can be a friend it just yeah it
creates a Brotherhood you know yeah I've
never gone to 12-step programs have been
like [ __ ] I shouldn't have coming
[ __ ] waste in my job it's always like
at least nice yeah it's at best
incredibly helpful and at least like oh
this is cool yeah
yeah I got in this year my program got
real small so I didn't have any of the
tools I was needing like I had no tools
I was just like holding on and our
podcast you it was just more about like
helping people and being involved in
people's lives and I just felt like
disconnected at some points and
and I should have just talked about that
like why I feel disconnected well I've
watched your thing about the you know
why you got sober thing yeah and that's
like one of your very popular clip of
yours right yeah yeah and that's what
that's what people like about you man
yes that you don't understand you've if
you were like a logo you'd be like a guy
just carrying a bunch of [ __ ] around
they don't like that guy right there
yeah you like you're like I don't know
what but it's like feelings it's just
like emotional [ __ ] and discomfort and
like you're walking around like I don't
know what to do peach cobbler it is one
of them down matches [ __ ] fireworks
like a bunch of clothes it's like wet
clothes like the dryer broke and you got
[ __ ] and you're looking for like a
place to set him down you're just
carrying a bunch of [ __ ] around looking
for a place to set it and that's your
appeal yeah that's like so and people
and watching you struggle is the emotion
is like the fun of it that's the like
not the fun of it but it's it's fun to
watch a guy who doesn't think he knows
what he's doing but you do know what you
like you if you talk it out you'll be
okay
yeah I just quit talking it out man yes
didn't have a place to talk it out and
then everything not everything
everything's good everything's okay
but my head started to swirl that
everything was you know just a lot of
negative things came in and and so then
I just wasn't I was living my dream and
not even enjoying uh
Tennessee not enjoying it but I felt
like I was just it was a I was just
scared I don't know I just felt [ __ ]
scared and it was a huge just a lot just
a lot of changes like well that's the
other thing people don't realize about
fame or success or something it is
isolating and it's a little ski
because you're like [ __ ] it's like
having a superpower samuri like [ __ ]
like people know me not just did [ __ ]
it's just different and it's less human
it's less human yes it's less of a human
it's less of a normal human experience
like even Fame a thousand years ago was
like every one of the Treadwell everyone
on the tribe knew everybody anyway but I
you got a little more respect you felt
like I'm the shaman and people think I'm
cool yeah a rock thrower yeah yeah I
throw I'm the [ __ ] road charter rocks
yeah the guy that [ __ ] and it's a one
guy and night by the fire yeah this huge
[ __ ] like big ass yeah I gotta sleep
yeah I gotta rest
yep so it is so when you get in these
situations where and then we also think
like famous people are kind of full of
[ __ ]
so or they're phony or they're like
putting it on so it just it's it it's a
lot of weird it's just a lot of weird
dynamics yeah which is why I it eats
everybody up oh you see it yeah and I
see it in a lot of these a rooms and
stuff like that you see a lot of people
and and that gets scary - it's like well
what do what what type of popularity do
you want how much do you want what is
it's just yeah it's just so all of that
just a lot of that coming in my head and
just trying to figure it out and not
having a lot of not going to a lot of
meetings and having like a look and
trust in those things it's a different
it's a different kind of discomfort like
it's like a new discomfort it's a new
it's a new way that you don't understand
the world
yeah like well I didn't understand the
world before and I've kind of figured it
out or I got out you escaped into this
other like well now I'm popular and
famous and successful and then you're in
that you're like uh [ __ ] this is its own
[ __ ] ball it's its own rules and
dynamics and [ __ ] yeah I just wanted to
feel like myself and I just good you
know and so now I'm working more towards
uh and it's not even working more I'm
just trying to just let go with stuff
and you know kind of trust a higher
power and
and just getting back into my program
more yeah and it makes me feel more
dialed in and makes me feel like I want
to help other people and and I hadn't
had that feeling for like about six
months and it's tough when that was like
the feeling that I loved the most was
acting like oh there's other people that
struggle and it's one thing I love about
you Neil is that you always like you're
good at talking about like and it's not
like self-pity [ __ ] it's just like this
is what's kind of going on in my head
yeah and how it's relating to the world
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one